que tous les plus grands tournois
d'échec il se déroulent en présentiel ou
en ligne vivez comprenez en direct les
parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentiels comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les comptes-rendus quotidien
les bio des joueurs les règles des
partages et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats pour tenter
de gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/avent ou c'est bien sur le
site internet que sur nos applications
iOS et Android pour vivre votre passion
comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour Fab
pour cette nouvelle journée
ouais
extraordinaire on va se délecter Fabien
ah ben j'avais hâte depuis hier
je me suis pas trop délecté dans cette
journée il y avait que le Tour de France
et du Wimbledon mais là ça y est 17h
il est l'heure d'être ici alors on
attend l'arrivée de Wesley Sow pour ce
cette première manche on va dire du
tournoi des losers ou des futurs
potentiels vainqueurs du tournoi donc on
rappelle bien sûr la spécificité de ce
tournoi Magnus Carlson qui n'a pas perdu
attends son opposant pour la grande
finale qui aura lieu demain
et Wesley Sow qui avait perdu en carte
finale tout comme d'ailleurs son
anniversaire du jour eaturid Zaga ont
jusque là franchi toutes les embûches
qui sont présentées à eux dans le
tournoi secondaire on va dire et sont
encore en ville s'affrontent donc dans
ce match au sommet et le 24 ce match
rejoindra donc
abdosa torovateur of qui avec gagné en
quart de finale en demi-finale mais qui
c'est un kiné hier contre manuscrit
Arson trop fort pour l'instant depuis le
début de ce tournoi mais on avait vu que
ça te RAF quand même à est mise à mal le
champion enfin l'ancien champion du
monde dans la troisième partie il avait
juste fait partie nul mais avait obtenu
une potion gagnante et aurait peut-être
pu revenir dans ce match j'aurais dit ça
t'auras bien sûr à cœur d'essayer de
briller et de retourner des pieds malus
Carlsen
dans la grande finale de demain donc
voilà on a enroule une sorte de
demi-finale donc ici qui va se profiler
entre Wesley sceaux et hit worry de Saga
et ensuite
la finale donc de ce loser bracket dans
la foulée dans la foulée
et donc voilà tout l'enjeu donc de cette
journée
donc je vois un que it Wasaga est bien
en ligne et connecté mais c'est pas le
cas de Wesley Sow donc on va attendre
je ne sais pas exactement à quelle heure
ils ont prévu de commencer nous on
pensait que ça serait vers 17h mais bon
chaque jour ça commence un petit peu en
retard peut-être ce sera vers 17h15
si jamais vous avez des infos dans le
chat n'hésitez pas à nous dire
voilà donc il doit être saga que je vois
en ligne je peux aller voir un petit peu
peut-être son historique
pour voir voir ce qu'il a fait
donc hier il a quand même éliminé Levan
à rognan en gagnant 2-0 il avait éliminé
Jordan van forest 2-0 également
leur a pas vraiment de zéro pardon
pardon il avait fait un partout et il
avait gagné la partie en Armageddon donc
voilà c'est ces deux victimes Jordan
vent forest eleven Aronian donc beau
parcours et c'est incliné donc contre
carwana au premier tour de de ce tournoi
mais comme vous le savez donc on a une
seconde vie un peu la brigade cachée de
ce tournoi qui permet de revenir de plus
belle pour pour la grande finale
voilà un petit peu l'invité surprise
mais qui joue bien ces temps-ci je crois
qu'ils étaient déjà qualifié dans une
édition précédente c'est un genre que
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de croiser ici
ou là dans les tournants en Espagne je
pense qu'il vient encore là-bas et ça
fait de nombreuses années Julien et
c'est un bon joueur aux alentours de de
2600 hello je peux les vérifier
peut-être non sur mon téléphone
sa page feed
pour voir
pour voir exactement son hello je vais
vous dire ça je vais aller faire la
petite recherche
il tourne Zaga
Eduardo je crois de son prénom
[Musique]
voilà Eduardo exactement
donc il est numéro 154 mondial
énorme 1989 donc il a 34 ans et la 2617
voilà et joue pour le drapeau espagnol
même si
les Sud-Américains de naissance
je sais plus son pays c'était la
Colombie ou
l'équateur ou un autre
je me souviens plus exactement en tout
cas voilà
je sais qu'il a représenté l'Espagne
lors des compétitions par équipe
peut-être lors des Olympiades lors des
championnats d'Europe les conditions
comme ça d'ailleurs je crois que cette
année il y aura un championnat d'Europe
où la France devrait jouer je ne sais
pas encore trop quels seront les joueurs
conviés à cette compétition mais
probablement que toi Zaga jouera pour
augmenter son nouveau pays l'Espagne
Espagne qui a quand même une belle
équipe avec
vaillir au pont ce qui pourrait jouer
peut-être
Anton gouiraro et puis aussi pas mal de
de joueurs un peu plus jeune maintenant
pas loin de 2700 Elo peut-être comme
Santos la tassa ou des joueurs comme ça
donc l'Espagne qui qui commence à être
une nation sérieuse qui peut être un
prétendant et bien sûr s'imposer dans
une compétition comme le championnat
d'Europe faudra compter sur
raconter sur l'Espagne voilà qui était
pas connu pour être une grande nation et
chicane et ils ont eu quand même
quelques bons joueurs par le passé déjà
grand maître construit dans les années
90 de ilyeskas par exemple mais pas de
là briller dans les fonctions par équipe
où il y a besoin d'un vivier de joueurs
mais maintenant ça a changé ils ont
laissé beaucoup de tournois moi j'aimais
beaucoup y aller dans les années 2000
là-bas jouer des Open et ça permet de
développer toute une génération de
joueurs et puis maintenant bien sûr avec
avec Internet et les ordinateurs de
toute façon il n'y a plus vraiment de
frontières et de barrières une formation
circulent librement et tout le monde
peut
devenir très fort voilà par mon Carlson
qui est norvégien alors que c'était pas
une terre d'échec au départ alors
maintenant bien sûr ça a changé les
servi un petit peu de pionniers là-bas
et maintenant c'est devenu un jeu très
populaire alors peut-être que si
rude venait à gagner un Grand Chelem il
se passe très peut-être au tennis tu vas
passer au foot avec la lande mais il y a
toujours besoin de modèles un petit peu
pour pour inspirer les générations
futures
toujours est-il donc Wesley je le vois
connecté avec son son chat en images de
profil donc je pense que le match ne
devrait plus trop tarder il est 17h12
allez on va dire que ça commence à 15
mais on ne sera pas à l'abri ça consiste
à 13 ou à 14 c'est quand même une des
possibilités
de l'horaire donc on est sur nos gardes
prêt à observer donc cette partie je ne
sais pas quel joueur aura les blancs au
départ mais nous verrons
et donc important c'est un parti avec
les pièces blanches évidemment vous
savez c'est des matchs en deux parties
seulement donc
en cas de en cas de défaite avec les
pièces blanches ça fait mal et c'est
très dur d'en venir dans le match on a
vu Fabienne au Carnon a essayé il y a
quand même tout tenté en jouant par
exemple une méthode ruizière mais la
malméisée avec un coup c'est ça avec un
petit rock et ça a permis à son
adversaire qui était d'ailleurs Wesley
Sow de rentrer dans son camp
donc voilà ça montre toute la difficulté
de l'emporter avec les pièces noires si
on doit absolument gagner pour revenir à
égalité sur son sur son adversaire
alors
n'oublie pas dans le chat vous avez une
minute de retard pour avoir ce que je
dis alors je vois qu'une question sur la
Belgique Shadoks la poser il y a un
petit moment à la Belgique
désolé je les vois pas aller gagner le
championnat d'Europe alors il y a darda
qui a un beau joueur en devenir qui a
plus de 2600 Elo mais il est peut-être
un peu seul il faudrait avoir quatre
cinq joueurs au moins de ce niveau là ou
encore plus fort pour aller s'imposer
dans les compétitions internationales
mais bien sûr dans son sillage peut-être
d'autres pour arriver il faudra voir et
puis peut-être qu'on aura des
révélations au nord de la Somme battle
et à ce moment-là peut-être de futurs
joueurs pour cette équipe nationale
belge
alors 17h14 peut-être plus qu'une minute
avant le début de la partie espérons je
vais appuyer sur ce bien aller
le suivre que si jamais ça commence mais
je vois bien que ce n'est pas parti
du coup à votre avis quel favori alors
de ce match puis de l'éventuelle finale
ensuite contre final finalement du
pauvre contre contre et qui voyez-vous
rejoindre Magnus
pour pour la grande finale de demain
final importantissime un moment clé et
un moment phare de la saison
donc il est 17h15
mon avis ça devrait pas tarder mais vous
savez je ne suis pas aux manettes
peut-être qu'on a encore ensemble à
regarder cette échiquier avec les pièces
en place pour le moment non ça y est
c'est parti donc c'est Wesley avec les
pièces blanches contre Eduardo history
Zaga et Wesley qui commence par le coup
E4
je l'ai souvent connu jouer le dragon
accéléré dans sicilienne devant accéléré
qu'on vous avait présenté dans une dans
des vidéos YouTube avec Kev mais il a
changé il a joué aussi ce second coup
c'est également une vente qui sait jouer
une chose il me semble qu'il y avait dû
jouer comme ça contre moi une fois à
Marrakech il y a déjà bien longtemps ça
doit être en 2010 ce tournoi
je me souviens de l'année parce que
c'était l'année de la coupe du monde de
foot c'était en même temps
et donc à 6 et westle qui a joué G3
alors c'est un coup qui vise à
développer le fonctionneo et qui ne met
pas le cas au C3 comme ça sur un coup
comme B5 le cahier ne serait pas
vulnérable en Citroën poussée B4 et donc
les blancs pourraient à tout moment
attaquer cette petite chaîne de pions
sans craindre la poussée du pion en B4
donc j'ai trois c'est jouer à ce propos
on peut aussi éventuellement développer
le fond E2 ou alors jouer C4 un étau de
moroxi pour ne pas avoir l'option avancé
plein de possibilités en souviens
qu'Etienne avait joué beaucoup H3 ici
assez subtil dans cette position contre
un joueur croate il me semble il avait
gagné la partie
j'ai trois en tout cas c'est un peu le
même genre de choses où on ne développe
donc pas ce qui allient ces trois trop
vite
alors dessus au noir de voir ce qu'ils
vont faire mais comme je vous l'ai dit
B5 c'est peut-être pas le coup de
l'année
ils peuvent songer donc à d'autres coups
de développement voir peut-être à
frapper vite au centre avec des cinq
parce que en cas d'échange dame prend il
pourrait toucher la tour en H1 alors sur
des seins qu'il faudrait peut-être
fermer avec avec 5 ou alors déplacer le
cavalier comme ça en cas d'échange on
échangera les dames on déracer le roi on
jouera la finale avec certains pions 4
mais un pion qu'on pourrait récupérer
ultérieurement
ou en tout cas c'est noir si accroche
avec F5 et cette structure comme ça en
rouge avec des pions aussi F5 et E4
peut-être ou G2 F3 cassé et ouvrir les
lignes avec le roi au centre il a choisi
cavalier F6
qui avait les filles donc coup de
développement qui venait à attaquer
espion faut juste de défense et décises
donc un petit développement
qu'on appelle structure de chez veningue
cette structure donc avec les pions des
6 aussi 6 qu'on voit donc très
régulièrement dans la sicilienne
donc petit
rackette qui va être joué par hitoris
saga alors il peut peut-être commencer
par damser ça tu peux peut-être jouer
kbdc dire ça en différentes options ici
mais faut 7 semble hyper logique côté
noir
mais
je dirais que j'aime bien le la position
pour wesler dans cette ouverture
simplement parce que il a pu vite se
développer et il peut déjà entreprendre
du jeu elle est le roi que ce soit par
F4 par G4 G5
ce four aurait pu le développer par ici
mais pourquoi pas peut-être B3 tous les
deux pour le mettre sur l'autre
diagonale qui pourra regarder vers le
petit rock adverse
on va voir
ce qu'il en est
un petit peu il aura peut-être bien aimé
jouer C4 sur un autre coup de son
adversaire là bien sûr dame C7 c'est
fait un peu pour contrarier cette idée
de des taux de morrozzi puisque s'il est
blanc nagent au C4 les Noirs pourraient
prendre bêtement donc il faut soit le
préparer soit se passer cette option et
jouer différemment alors pour préparer
on pourrait peut-être faire dame 2
pourquoi pas on peut aussi se développer
avec faux-3 ça semble légitime pourquoi
pas B3 peut-être une option mais voilà
c'est sûrement des coûts normaux aux
trois dame de deux coups il semble pas
mal côté blanc on verra en tout cas si
Wesley décide de jouer ainsi ou si notre
idée derrière la tête il joue B3 donc
voilà c'était encore une option
totalement possible donc ça prépare
l'arrivée du pion C4 et ça peut préparer
le développement du fond en fonction de
kéto en B2 donc avec deux fous
l'ascension de keto qui pourrait avoir
leur rôle à jouer sur les grandes
diagonales de l'échiquier
par la suite de la partie
donc des trois jouets
et toi mais faire attention avec les
noirs de pas jouer des coups trop
passif parce qu'on peut vite se
retrouver sous pression après C4
[Musique]
des coups très naturels comme ça et puis
aussi faut pas oublier que les lampes
peuvent jouer avec F4 G4 G5 de l'autre
côté on a un petit peu vu de scénario
hier dans une partie de de Magnus
Carlson d'ailleurs la deuxième du match
je crois contre Abdou satorov dans
laquelle il avait utilisé cette
avalanche de pions allez le Leroy
et une très bonne position même si
ensuite c'était compliqué il a quand
même fini par gagner la partie mais ça
aurait pu tourner différemment
donc en tout cas il t'aurais déjà
réfléchi après ce coup B3
et donc on attend de voir
quel schéma il va utiliser pour se
développer
donc pour l'instant il peut pas vraiment
je vais baisser un qui était une idée de
ce coaciste déjà à cause des coûts comme
A4 pour attaquer la structure mais
surtout à cause de 5 qui ouvrira des
ménage attaque la tour attaque le
cavalier etc donc pour l'instant ce pion
ne peut pas trop se déplacer de sa quasi
initiale il a choisi foueset donc coup
de développement pour rocker par la
suite alors je vais l'arrivée de Kev
j'ai bien écouté le truc en anglais oui
donc ça commence bien à 17h15 en fait
d'accord donc il y a pas eu de retard
alors il tourise un gars est plus fort
dans tous les domaines du jeu d'après
une chaise quasiment mais il est moins
précis d'accord et plus fort partout
mais joue moins souvent les bons coups
c'est un peu étonnant comme concept mais
on va le croire
au même niveau pression les ouvertures
ça va aussi mais précisions globales
donc plus fort mais moins fort c'est
bon c'est une chaise en même temps on va
faire confiance quand même c'est quand
même très précis trop compris
mais c'est vrai que ce il est plus fort
dans les petits secteurs mais moins fort
globalement quoi OK
non mais c'est vrai que tu te dis au
tennis un mec qui a un meilleur coup
droit un meilleur revers un meilleur
service
qui court mieux qui couvre bien son
terrain qui a de l'endurance bah
forcément il est moins bon en fait
meilleur pourcentage de première balle
mais bon on a un autre côté ouais je
sais plus j'ai pas trop en fait non
en tout cas ça c'est sûr ok il avait une
grosse différence
il ne le lâche plus alors après est-ce
que ça peut venir de l'adversité aussi
qui a l'habitude de jouer contre les
meilleurs mondiaux c'est toujours très
dur de te voir aussi peut-être qu'il a
des meilleurs stats mais qu'on des
joueurs moins fort c'est possible
c'est comme si tu gagnes plus de jeux
que tu fais plus de ce que tu convertis
plus de balles de vrai enfin tu fais
tout mieux mais bon enfin tu veux que
des challengers et l'autre je joue que
des grands
et donc c'était pour ça que en fait il
est mieux sur toutes les statistiques
sauf sur la précision
ceci explique en peut être cela
en fait c'est la même chose pour tout ça
toraphyr parce que j'avais pas compris
c'est qu'en fait il était plus fort dans
tout
sauf dans la précision de partir
donc oui c'est sûrement à cause de
l'adversité quoi
sur la statistique prend pas en compte
quoi il y avait pas la moyenne et l'eau
des adversaires pour ça que souvent
quand on est sur cheesecom et qu'on joue
des parties et qu'à la fin on fait le
bilan quand toujours dans un pas très
fort tu fais souvent 98,99 parce que il
y a pas trop de résistance en face et
c'est toujours plus simple de bien jouer
contre les coups viennent naturellement
et que tu as du matériel en plus
alors quand tu es vite mis en difficulté
c'est délicat toujours faire les bons
choix
ok oui
donc quoi qu'il en soit voilà
l'expliquer à Sion de ce que j'ai vu non
ils m'ont remontré des extraits bah il
était pas bien par Ham c'est qualifié on
va t'en parler vous avez tous les deux
une seconde et c'est pas rame qui est
tombé quoi il avait pas l'air bien
d'ailleurs parram hier qui a perdu
contre Praga lambda et j'ai eu la stats
que le jeune Indien d'ailleurs dépassait
le les 2700 et l'eau au classement
virtuel mais donc si
s'il maintient ce niveau de jeu il
dépasse RA donc au premier août lors de
la parution de la prochaine liste donc
qui n'a pas 18 ans il me semble
et Parame qui doit pas être bien ah bah
du coup non
jamais bien après une défaite
non
qu'est-ce qui a eu d'autre comme un faux
importantes
deuxième division
il y a un gars qui est pas venu jouer
hier
je quitte ou l'oublier ou apparemment et
autre chose à faire
mais c'était prévu dans le tournoi ou
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas il est
pas venu se tabataba et mais revient
aujourd'hui quand même en looser bracket
[Musique]
qui peuvent revenir et regagner quoi
les divisions 3 il y a du yangi il y a
du Dominguez
même plus forte que les autres quoi
mais ils étaient à fond pour historique
Zaga sur le truc dans le live ouais
je sais que ceux qui sont habitués du
stream sont là tous les jours M voir
cette pièce d'art et ceux qui ne l'ont
pas encore vu à pression sur
ça vaut le coup d'œil
mais dans quoi cette deuxième division
qui a l'air fort intéressante c'est vrai
que on ne la suis pas assez Fabien
non alors peut-être pour les futurs
retransmission faudrait qu'on soit de
l'ouverture des matchs je sais pas c'est
quoi 14 heures peut-être je pense
arriver des milliers en place
et donc tu gagnes la division 2 je crois
que tu joues en division à la fois
d'après ah quand même d'accord
donc il y a un grand enjeu
donc on rappelle le prochain tournoi
aura lieu fin août
Coupe du monde donc entre qui servira de
tremplin
l'étape de transition entre ces deux
tournois
en tout cas ce sera beau
toi aussi tu es à fond pour une
moi je j'observe j'observe ce match je
ne vais pas
être partisan juste là pour être
objectif et pour personne voilà je ne
peux pas me permettre
d'être pour quelqu'un
on va avoir deux magnifiques matchs
aujourd'hui voilà la vainqueur de ce
match qui rencontrera d'où ça t'auras
donc une journée extraordinaire
qui réfléchit il a des coups naturels
comme fou B2 peut-être ou trois de
l'autre côté pour terminer son
développement
il semble logique alors il doit calculer
où est-ce que le fullmue glacé quelle
est la meilleure diagonale
alors on nous demande d'être une chaîne
dédiée Youtube pour la D2 alors il y a
une chaîne c'est les chaises dojo ah oui
qui suivent la chaîne dédiée pour la
deuxième division d'accord
mais est-ce le monsieur qu'on avait
croisé le week-end dernier
mais donc il y a 2 jours en fait
d'accord il y a deux jours
il y a un chasse d'autres jours et un
chasse master
ers
mettre fille de Dow JO
un calife c'est beau le Play INSA
s'appelle
c'est un des plus beaux moments
évidemment le playing c'est là qu'il y a
pas RAM qui était pas bien
et qui a pas participer
sont très difficiles
c'est une concurrence mondiale
tout autour de la planète des milliers
de joueurs s'affrontent
ils rêvent tous de participer
et non et non je n'ai pas encore essayé
tu vas essayer je pense pas
demain je pourrais te voir à fond quoi
après elle est belle quand même
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais j'ai peur que
la concurrence peut-être trop forte
mais je crois qu'il y a quasi aucun
Français qui joue
[Musique]
deux fois mais il dit que c'est kata il
aime pas
Jul et Maxime et à lire et ça mais
Maxime il veut pas trop jouer
Mathieu qui passe 5 minutes tous les
jours et ben détrompe-toi Mathieu nous
nous délectons de cette compétition
on est pas assez spécialiste aussi sur
internet je sais pas je sais pas
peut-être manque de spécialisation
possible j'en sais rien après j'avance
des
hypothèses ici ou là après peut-être
Mathieu pourra nous dire pourquoi il a
pas joué ce tournoi tenter tenter la
calife
beaucoup de joueurs qui se qualifient à
quelque chose
alors Wesley qui a mis son roi H2
j'imagine qu'il veut préparer F4 parce
que ça aurait été dangereux d'aligner la
dame et le roi le long de cette
diagonale j'ai un à 7 parce que non
aurait peut-être pu jouer un coup comme
des 5 randonnée view fossette et venir
en C5 faire une enfilade
maintenant avec un roi ici il peut
peut-être se le permettre même si le
coup damassin qui est peut-être malin de
la part directement H5
quand même
semi-piège mais piège quand même il veut
qu'il y ait des cinq je pense
exactement souvent
le courant est fuite
de récupérer ce qui avait la recette
mais parfois ce genre de piège ou une
pièce
avec la paire de fou
de Tours sur la colonne D plus peut-être
le fois à 3 qui arriverait ensuite
fait quand même
partir en jeun avec son
jeu du chat et de la souris avec son
adversaire lui étant bien sûr le chat et
il doit dans le rôle de la souris
après est-ce que la souris est toujours
chassée pas toujours
on connaît les cartoons
elle te disait un truc en cas de grosses
avec ils sont autorisés
on verra il n'y a pas encore
au courant en France en fait peut-être
juste ça la raison en fait même moi
j'avais pas trop vu passer l'info après
je sais pas si j'étais disponible si
c'était le weekend dernier de toute
façon
[Musique]
aléatoire des fois ça change mais tu
dois recevoir un mail en fait
souvent tu vois je prends ça pour du
spam je clique je supprime je lis même
pas et moi après toujours pas de toute
façon
quoi qu'il en soit non non mais moi je
pense que j'aurais pas mais
mais en gros tu vois j'y pense même pas
quoi
mais Mathieu non plus non
non
plus il a pas trop la tête a joué
qui sent pas trop en forme en bide etc
etc
malheureusement sinon
tu peux regarder à fond
sur le jeu comme fr non non dommage
peut-être une fois
c'était la dernière
infernale
en fait c'est très très très très très
long
c'est pour ça que c'est que c'est que
les phases finales qui sont vraiment
suivies
mais ça permet d'être bien sûr
important il y a pas parrain
qui a mis le four à trois
mais qui se place vite je ne manœuvre
jeu de jambes même
parce que
franchement tout peut se passer
elle est blanc on peut mettre la marche
avant un moment
les noirs sont plus en stratégie
d'attente mais ils guettent s'il y a un
B5 possible un dessin possible une
petite percée à mon autre
ouais
bon
il a perdu son avantage autant qu'il
avait peut-être au début de la partie
avec ce coup qui a lieu quand même
peut-être se diriger vers la case F4 et
poser des questions à la dame adverse
alors qui serait pas encore enfermé
qu'il y a des cases disponibles
ça serait E5 G5 H6 mais bon maintenant
il faut compter sur ce genre de
possibilités
à la cheville est-ce que ça peut
pénaliser
bon on pourrait penser que non quand tu
joues aux échecs et que tu fais marcher
la tête mais c'est quand même une
douleur latente donc c'est chiant et tu
te déplaces moins bien et puis peut-être
tu as pas la tête à ça donc oui ça
pénalise d'une manière ou d'une autre
ça te pénalise moins que si tu étais
genre de tennis ou de foot mais
ça reste un peu chiant et puis bon on va
voir Mathieu ce qu'il en dit
l'intéresser pourra peut-être mieux nous
expliquer une minute trente un décalage
dans une minute 30 on aura l'explication
si on se rappelle la question qu'on
avait posé
on a vu que le chat est pas méga actif
non plus je pense que ça va aller
un peu dommage hein
de décalage pour interagir quand même
au contraire c'est bon
c'est un peu le défaut d'être parti avec
le cavalier
F4 attendu pour attaquer la dame
qui a donc trois cases à cette
disposition
5 G5 H6
choisi H6
faire
la dame pour défendre 4 qui s'enlève
peut-être vis-à-vis avec la dame H6 et
puis qui sait un jour peut-être monter
la tour C en C3 C2 quelque part ramener
le foncé 1 et peut-être créer
des thèmes de vis-à-vis avec la dame
avec des découvertes éventuelles
dames de jouets aussi le trader c'est
qu'elle couvre la caisse G4 on craint
plus les kij4 échec on pourrait
peut-être même à jour pousser le pion à
plus tard pour l'instant mais sur le
pion doit défendre le cavalier F4
et ouais cela en tout cas qui ne se
pressent pas qui se met en place
normalement il est assez bon dans ce
genre de partie
je pense
après je suis un peu fait griser
peut-être par les commentaires tchécom
donné quasiment tous les favori
sur le chat
en ce moment là je peux pas enfin on
s'en fout mais oui trop long à suivre ce
tournoi est trop dommage je comprends le
système
ah bah il y a un winner un loser bracket
et puis après ça revient ça redescend
au contraire tu peux te délecter de
d'une plus grande quantité de match
Fabien
et on fera remonter cette idée de faire
jouer les matchs en décalés
tout au long de la journée il passe
aujourd'hui au final 4 5 heures voilà
comme aujourd'hui très bien mais là on
en a que deux et des matchs en 2,7 enfin
en deux parties gagnantes donc on
restera quoi qu'il en soit un petit peu
sur votre faim on aimerait bien qu'il y
ait des matchs en quatre parties plus
l'armée Guédon et qu'il est quatre
matchs d'affilée là bon on serait on
serait très bien
mais en décalé mais en décalé tout à
fait voilà
après pourquoi pas garder peut-être ce
schéma pour
[Musique]
et donc
voilà c'est peut-être dommage
en tout cas
qui défend E4 H5 sur le côté pas bête
il compte sûrement un espion jusqu'en H4
et poser une question pion G3 s'il
venait à se déplacer du coup il y aura
un petit trou en F4 et ce serait
beaucoup plus dur pour les blondes F4
pour même par la suite et puis si les
blancs se laissent échanger trois qui
reprennent de F bon bah à ce moment là
pareil il y aura peut-être du cavalier
H5 qui arriverait et puis de toute façon
plus faible et la cage F4 éventuellement
donc pas bête
du tout et puis éviter ça par H4 par les
Blancs eux-mêmes ben malheureusement ça
affaiblit la case G4 c'est l'option
quand même choisi par Wesley mais le
cavalier pourrait venir dessus
non c'est une très bonne case pour le
pour le cavalier ça
non pas du tout ce délecter là
après ouais je me disais que c'était
sûrement son idée
mais bon F3 c'est dommage pour le fou G2
il repart avec le cavalier
ouais je me disais peut-être sur F3 il
aurait pu attendre aller en H6 avec le
cavalier une petite nul
on peut se délecter de cette répétition
c'est pas une belle partie non c'est une
très belle partie mais peut-être que
Wesley va quand même continuer
tu penses il peut nous jouer autre chose
prends des risques
complètement inattendu
une fébrilité chez l'adversaire qui
serait contenté de la nul et il se dit
autre chose alors qui joue maintenant de
l'autre côté le coût de l'accordéon un
coup à droite un coup à gauche le pion
HP le pion
il peut nous refaire une petite
répétition deux fois mais il y a
sûrement pas la faire trois fois
peut-être dame 2 qui est F6 d'un E3
cavalier j'ai 4 il peut être Dame des
deux à ce moment-là
j'espère
et donc oui je me disais ce qui est en
G4 il est quand même pas si mal parce
que si on fait F3 pour le chasser il
pourrait peut-être même aller en H6
peut-être il a pas envie de jouer F5
trop vite tant que le fouget d'eau n'est
pas enterré parce que bien sûr c'est un
échange des fous de cases blanches
certes ça échangerait le fou du fiant
qui est au des blancs mais le roi n'est
pas vraiment faible et du coup ça sur
l'innirait surtout
surligner les cases blanches affaiblit
un peu partout B5 des 5 4 et la mauvaise
structure pion des noirs avec ce fouet
fuite derrière ses pions de case noir
peut-être quand même
ah non il échange les dames
parce que si on ramène le pion G5 pour
être attrapé
ouais c'est bien joué
plus que 45 secondes quand même pour une
Tori Zaga
mais il est peut-être très très fort
quand il doit jouer vite est-ce qu'ils
ont dit très précis quand il faut jouer
vite donc
pas vraiment d'inquiétude sur ce plan là
c'est vrai qu'on avait vu qu'on te
Fabiano mis à part le fait il avait pas
réussi à cliquer le coup quoi exactement
mais sinon il avait bien joué ce qu'il a
appris à appuyer sur Alt on verra
peut-être plus tard dans la partie ou
dans ce match
je suppose que oui
il a peut-être modifié les paramètres et
juste enlever l'autocollant
en fait c'est bien d'avoir l'auto Quinn
c'est juste qu'il faut savoir le alt
quoi
mais attention pas halte gros
ça fait quoi as-tu ferais juste
technique alt vraiment à gauche de la
barre d'espace sur un clavier
de fait perdre ne pas confondre les deux
alors une 38 contre 36 secondes partie
qui va s'animer
on a vu un échange des fous de casse
blanche plutôt une bonne opération pour
Wesley a priori puisque c'était son
mauvais fou
mais ça reste solide
de part et d'autre mais Wesley peut
travailler encore la position et
peut-être ce qui ait des trois là qui
est plus si bien placé mais pensez à la
ramener en E1 puis en C2
et enfin avoir accepté à la case des 5
magnifique 4 centrale et ou F5 peut-être
aussi avoir
ça il tombe en dessous des 20 secondes
il a dû entendre
bruit stressant
qu'au 15 juin
il y a un plugin sur Google
et quant à moins de 20 secondes ou moins
de 10 ça dit move move move move move
mais je crois que c'est pire que rien
ça te stresse à fond non
qualité ok intéressante intéressante il
aurait pu parler la menace avec F4 mais
ça aurait pu affaiblir son roi donc il
gagne position très cohérente avec cela
dit une qualité de retard alors les
tours pour l'instant n'ont pas avant de
colonne pour s'exprimer mais ça reste du
matériel en plus mais ce qui a de bien
pour Wesley c'est qu'avec la disparition
de ce pion à 5 il aura la case B4 pour
le cavalier et puis il a surtout toutes
les cases noires
qui sont faibles
qui va arriver en dessin qui va être
très dominant et là il a moins de 5
secondes
plus de cases
il y a trop de fourchette
mais si pour enchaîner avec des fous
principes qui est des 5 endroits
avec la petite turbine aussi mais
c'était un coup très logique ça ça a
gagné la partie immédiatement
il y avait plus de coups
pour history Zaga
ce qu'ils ont dit moi j'ai les infos les
infos de chascom et ils doivent regarder
ici à peu de temps il tourne Zaga
beaucoup plus précis
brainshad il a pas fait j'ai 5 mais il
ramène ça dans mon jeu qui est quand
même relativement logique et attaque H4
peut appeler une tour Eiffel
ou en G7 pour faire G5 ensuite
voilà il joue pour G5 clairement ça
donne envie pour l'attaquer trois blancs
qui a peut-être courir avec deux partir
un de l'autre côté de l'échiquier mais
là tout peut se passer maintenant c'est
il y a plus rien de contrôle dans la
position
et B6 sur la place son cavalier le roi
qui s'en va comme prévu mais il y a du
jeu en face attention je joue pas mal
hein des deux côtés là
et peut-être ça va répéter la dame bouge
5 dame j'ai un nouveau non pas de répète
il prend sa chance
qui contrôle beaucoup de casse trouver
par Wesley ça peut encore retourner
tu es trop F1 pour défendre latéralement
avec cette dame de le pion de l'autre
côté
bien joué
allez là ils ont 10 secondes chacun ça
va être plus précis il a fait à 4
regarder son roi où il était qui
soutient le cavalier mais la dame
s'infiltre et attaque maintenant le pion
B3 dame prend H 4 attaque le cavalier F6
est-ce que tu sens la précision du
joueur espagnol là pour l'instant
c'était pas mal il a bien
[Musique]
protéger tout ça
échecs maintenant
allez ça bouffe le Punto
F5 il voulait être sur D7 c'était bien
joué en fait de sa part il gagne le pion
E5 important et tout le cavalier au
passage
ça y est il y a toutes les pièces qui
rentrent ça va être matte il a été plus
précis mais moins précis quand même
j'ai eu le seul coup dame 5 étant des 7
c'était la précision de Schrödinger
magnifique partie Fabien une partie qui
voilà qui laisse Wesley vraiment course
pour ce magnifique trophée Fabien
et donc Wesley a une marche à une marche
de rejoindre à 12h30 tout à l'heure donc
je vous propose qu'on fasse une petite
pause pour se remettre de nos émotions
et qu'on se retrouve
dès que possible pour le début de la
prochaine partie
[Musique]
et on est de retour Fabien c'est reparti
se délecter
et donc on est côté où est-ce les sceaux
on a on a les pièces noires ici
qui a choisi un double pion de kéto une
voiture un peu éthique il tombe dans une
Benoni inversée on va dire alors je
t'arrête tout de suite Fabien parce que
tu as quand même oublié de préciser ce
truc chose très importante c'est quoi
dans le loser bracket et donc c'est en
première un point et demi c'est le
meilleur des deux parties donc avant
exactement l'ouverture c'est important
quand même de rappeler rappeler Fabien
les règles du tournoi pensez à les
rappeler avant la partie précédente mais
là oublie une attention oublie bête ça
c'est quand même important que de la nul
pour se qualifier exactement donc avec
les Blancs il doit peut-être devoir
prendre tous les risques en tout cas
pour l'instant il joue une ouverture qui
joue
c'est à dire où il y a pas tellement de
ventes forcées et forçantes pour tout
échanger et faire des nuls en force on
va être obligé de jouer des coups de
jouer aux échecs
exactement Fabien exactement
donc je t'ai coupé dans ton élan mais
bon c'est quand même important de
rappeler l'enjeu de la partie quand même
c'était quand même beaucoup plus
important qui sera une finale hein
final oui et non
c'est demain mais ce sera déjà la finale
du loser bracket un petit te ramène vers
le winner
tout en étant un loser
mais un looser à guéri un loser qui sera
allé jusqu'au bout et qui méritera sa
place
face à Magnus un Magnus quand on appelle
a été absolument impérial jusqu'à lors
ok oui
Zaga qui était le favori du cast en
anglais
peut-être toujours peut-être il l'est
toujours
alors que nous vous le savez nous sommes
très objectif et on ne prononce pas à ce
sujet
c'est vraiment j'apprécie un ton
objectif à toute épreuve
tu ne te prononces que rarement
finalement exactement c'est quand même
la qualité première d'un journaliste je
pense
totalement Fabien totalement
alors et toi bien j'espère pousser B4 et
faire une expansion donc reprendre de
l'espace avec cette majorité il a trois
pions contre deux donc elle dame il
aimerait arriver B4 pourquoi pas B5 ou
C5 par la suite donc Wesley enfin
sûrement essayer de l'éviter alors
est-ce qu'il va faire à 5 à 5 ça coûte
très logique mais ça pourrait permettre
l'arrivée du Caval C2 en B5 via la Casa
3 mais en vrai quand même on va partir
en B8 avec le fou après oui on se cache
mais le calvaire V5 comme très bien
placé et c'est pas ce qu'elle pion à 5
que les Blancs auraient dit leur dernier
mot puisqu'il pourrait aussi mettre le
pion à 3
petit à petit avancé donc donc avoir si
si Wesley compte jouer ce coup à 5
ou pas
mais positions
qui joue
qui joue bien
mais l'avantage semble quand même être
côté ouais c'est disons dans ce genre de
position
souvent l'ordinateur va préférer le camp
qui a l'Espace contre la Benoni
mais quand c'est des humains qui jouent
tout est possible tout est possible donc
c'est plutôt une bonne opération pour
utorise la finalement si on en suit tes
préceptes Fabien exactement je pense il
peut être content de l'issue de
l'ouverture et ce qui est en train de se
passer sur l'échiquier
c'est quand même rester sourd pour le
moment qui est devant dans ce match
maintenant
mais il doit pas forcément se délecter
Fabien de cette ouverture non non
préféré autre chose
d'ailleurs il réfléchit
c'est vrai que j'aime bien cette cadence
de 15 + + 3 ça permet d'avoir bien le
temps oui de bien réfléchir de jouer de
manière très précise
et à la limite du genre rapide
c'est rapide tout en étant lent dans le
domaine du rapide
très très belle qui a danse
si la cadence 25 + 10 qui existent
peut-être encore un petit peu meilleur
c'est pour moi la cadence déjà déjà plus
intéressantes
bien qu'en pro de châssis que ce soit
des cadences
plutôt longue
oui
mais d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est cadence
là oui un peu plus rare en général quand
même sur Internet
ça se fait pas les mêmes impressions
quand c'est tournoi de souvenirs rapides
du dimanche
trouve pas ça si mais là sur Internet
comme on a tellement l'habitude de jouer
des Blitz
ça paraît
ça passe presque pour des parties
je sais qu'il y avait eu dans un moment
le projet qui n'a pas suivi de faire des
tournois en
lentement sur Internet
pendant c'était pendant le confinement
il y avait eu ce projet mais qui n'avait
pas vu le jour malheureusement dommage
c'est vrai de jouer en cadence je crois
qu'ils avaient dû faire quand même des
tournois des Olympiades en ligne des
avaient quand même privilégié une
cadence rapide
j'ai le souvenir peut-être des
qualifications pour la Coupe du monde
les joueurs français est allé au château
de danières ah ouais
donc Isaac a un petit peu mis en place
cela et malheureusement ça c'est bien
dommage ce n'est pas pris peut-être sera
que partir remise on espère en tout cas
on aura un directeur adjoint de la fille
qui remettra l'idée sur le tapis
et peut-être ça passera cette fois alors
bien sûr faut que le public suive mais
je n'ai pas de doute ils auront un réel
engouement pour pour un tel tournant
c'est quand même un relativement beau
alors que ça réfléchit un côté
ou 4 donc je pars
laisse le pion des quatre emprises
donc les blancs pourraient avoir envie
de faire cavalier F prendre des quatre
après vous calculez les conséquences
peut-être qu'à les prendre
des trois du coup et là on peut pas le
faire du coup de dire bon bah je dois
prendre en 4 mais on voit donc l'arrivée
du cavalier à ce moment-là la fourchette
en C3 donc il doit évaluer les
conséquences peut-être d'inscrivez de
qualité de prendre des 4 à ce moment-là
qui est croit même ces deux qui prend
bien dame prend bien parce que ça donne
ça pas l'air méga convaincant et donc
peut-être après pion conquête qui prend
4 faire un coup comme foubedo au final
pour couvrir cette case C3 tout en
attaquant une fois de plus le pion des 4
il faudrait quand même suivre qui a
laissé trois faut prendre si on prend et
on aura la qualité matérielle les Nord a
gagné la paire de fou mais un pion c'est
trois peut-être quand même un peu isolé
je sais que cela beaucoup réfléchi pour
jouer ainsi et dame qui arrive en F6
quand même
bon on va laisser les joueurs prendre
leur décision
ce sont eux les maîtres à bord
et donc après ce match on aura la suite
de du
user bracket entre guillemets avec Abdou
sa torov qui attend la patiemment
de faire son entrée dans l'arène
exactement alors qu'on propose une
carence de trois heures plus une heure
de 40e coups côté Frank Aria
qui rebondissait sur la conversation que
nous avions précédemment ce serait une
belle cadence effectivement trois heures
chacun plus une heure
ne pas oublier alors peut-être pas d'une
heure mais bien de 45 ou 30 minutes si
jamais un petit peu dynamiser tout ça
quand même un moment mais
rien n'est moins sûr ne sont pas trop
fou non plus quand même et sur la même
des arbitres
cadences encore que je pense que si
c'est les meilleurs qui jouent on peut
leur faire confiance
bien évidemment
ça va indispensable
et peut-être que le public serait
content et rassuré
en tout cas ça réfléchit côté espagnol
oui ils vont vers quelle décision il
prend de toute façon on a à peu près
fait le tour des enjeux dans la position
après à lui de voir donc s'il prend le 4
et qui fait fou B2 ou s'il décide de
prendre des cartes tout de suite c'est
un peu bizarre mais
mais peut-être
éliminer hier par West
c'est pour ça qu'on se posait la
question hier si tu as suivi le live mon
Grey il ne faudrait-il pas un troisième
possibilité d'élimination une troisième
vie dans ces tournois comme dommage hein
aussi vite c'est la question que c'est
posée hier pendant la retransmission on
a on n'a pas la réponse
ça nous semble quand même
logique
en tout cas ça irait dans la logique je
trouve que son bo2 ça va très très vite
il y a eu les problèmes de qualité d'air
chez karwana on va remettre la qualité
d'air chez Carona
et on voit qu'il a il a un petit peu
réglé le CO2 ah bah là il a une belle
qui était derrière c'est dommage qu'il
joue plus tu vois
regarde il a réglé l'humidité
c'est dommage qu'ils étaient éliminé et
là ouais c'est cette idée d'un troisième
tour en 3e bracket prends tout son sens
on voit que jour en jour il a amélioré
tout ce qui pouvait et là il serait
vraiment dans les conditions optimale
pour jouer alors bien sûr il peut pas
faire grand-chose la température
extérieure mais quand même voilà Jordan
qualité ce serait de genre qui serait au
maximum de leur forme
aujourd'hui quand même il revient un
petit peu mais c'est humide et il fait
chaud hein il doit il doit suer quand
même mais chez David ce qu'on voit chez
David
c'est pas mal alors personne est
complètement tout dans le verre cela dit
on peut un peu laisser cette qualité
chez caroanna quand même exactement
et oui c'est c'est dommage parce qu'il a
réussi à régler ses problèmes mais
finalement sur le tard
et du coup bon la bonne nouvelle c'est
que pour le tournoi qui aura lieu fin
août peut-être que là il sera fin prêt
qu'il aura mis tous les réglages en
place et qui aura bien fait travailler
ses mécano justement dans l'élaboration
d'une d'une belle pièce qui permettra de
jouer à un moment de venir
et on voit surtout cette humidité qui
était sur du 53 52% hier on la voyait un
petit peu baisser
et c'est que aujourd'hui qu'on réussit à
revenir vers du 38%
alors peut-être qu'il y a moins de CO2
parce qu'il est pas dans la pièce aussi
ça peut jouer c'est possible de
l'ordinateur est éteint vous êtes
devrait-il jouer à distance de cette
pièce
voilà il en pourrait
une autre pièce
mais bon en tout cas il pourra quand
même bluffer comme ça même si l'autre
pièce c'est pas terrible parce que
l'adversaire bah ça fait peur de voir
genre tel condition tu te dis oulala
sauce je vais te manger
il fait 29 peut-être encore un peu plus
j'imagine qu'à force de CO2 va monter
des transmissions de virus à ce
moment-là et
donc
voilà tu te sens beaucoup mieux quoi
exactement
dans la partie en tout cas il est pris
l'option de prendre E4 fuit par fluide
pour contrôler cette caisse C3 il est
quand même de se faire échanger et il a
suivi par cavalier E3 dans ce cavalier
qui veut se rediriger vers la case D5
une belle case centrale pour peut-être
aller croquer par la suite ce pion C3
on va voir comment comment être les
continue Fabien
qui propose de jouer dehors carrément
peut-être un petit peu à Londres sous un
arbre
peut-être finalement ça l'idée
c'est pas idiot non non c'est une bonne
idée
c'est possible étant donné que souvent
on conseille d'ailleurs
qu'on fait rentrer l'air extérieur qui
doit se permettre de meilleure qualité
j'imagine
tu vas mettre un boîtier dehors
un beau test à faire
au niveau du CO2 tu dois être quand même
mieux
ouais
très clairement
ça te permet vraiment de mieux jouer
après la température ça peut être
problématique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pensais être sous les arbres peut-être
dans une forêt
tu viens avec ton groupe électrogène et
tu branches ton ordi
c'est pas bête ça
aurait été testé pour le prochain
peut-être je peux voir une petite
rivière tu tires ruisseau les pieds dans
l'eau pour voir quand même cette
fraîcheur
qui diffuse
tu as des bonnes idées fables
une rivière
ça donne sur un bateau en fait faudra
bien le fraîcheur de l'eau
après rester
en réseau
avec le moins important finalement
c'est vrai est-ce que est-ce que si par
exemple tu as un problème par exemple tu
viens de peindre quelque chose comme on
dit ou si c'est à coté d'une usine
est-ce que ça a détecté en CO2 les les
particules chimiques dans l'air ou ça et
si on est en train de me poser c'est
possible un boîtier très évolué et donc
je sais pas non mais faudra qu'on
demande ça Fabien je demanderai est-ce
que ça ça capte les résidus chimiques
c'est une bonne question qui est posée
dans le chat
alors ouais qui a joué le quoi 5
il n'a pas pris la peine de le défendre
il le donne mais il pousse il pousse ce
Piona d'aller un petit peu taquiné la
chaîne de pion adverse et ouvrir
éventuellement la tour à 8 voir pousser
sur la 3 pour toujours avoir du cavalier
B4 pour l'attaquer le pion à deux
avoir donc comment ça va suivre en tout
cas il a un purement donc
des chances avec les Blancs et puis au
moins c'est pas rien
mais il y a la paire de fou donc on dit
souvent une carte fou peut commencer à
un pion on a vu plein d'ouvertures ou
c'est le cas notamment le grand Marshall
dans l'espagnol ou dans de nombreuses
finales avec le pion de moi les Noirs
s'en sortent très bien grâce à cette
paire de fous après faut avoir envie il
faut avoir envie mais j'ai l'impression
que voici lait
sans trop de peur
pour échanger peut-être ceux qui avaient
les dessins ils sont en attaquant le
pion à deux
donc il y a des changes qu'entreprendre
avec le fou attaquer la tour il y aurait
peut-être en C2 il pourrait peut-être
prendre un B3 à ce moment-là et rentrer
avec le tour à 3
et où en D3
presser un peu ce pionception
qui a bien jugé tout ça
il y a pas une vision très risqué mais
bon faut quand même pas trop se tromper
dans ces dans ces positions
c'est son style
c'est pas cramique il en a à son nom
d'enchaîner des clopes pour le perturber
non c'était c'est peut-être beau de
vinyle plutôt sur la gueule
[Musique]
pas trop ça il voulait être mis dans des
situations inconfortables dès
l'entraînement pour justement supporter
un niveau de stress en match en
compétition c'est un bel entraînement
était autorisé
on a connu ça nous-même pendant
longtemps
pas forcément les salles d'échecs même
si au tout début moi c'était un peu
comme ça mais
jusqu'en 2008 même dans les bars et
restaurants
on a perdu l'habitude mais c'est pas si
longtemps finalement
mais c'est bien que ce soit arrêté on
parle qualité d'air c'est vraiment
mauvais pour la santé pas que celui qui
fume mais les fumeurs passif aussi
mais là
alors ça ça se verrait sur le boîtier ou
pas est-ce que ça dure en CO2 la fumée
j'ai pas des grandes connaissances sur
ce sujet
en tout cas d'aller change entre les
deux joueurs et autoritzaga et Wesley
Sow
arrive un petit peu plus
mettre sous pression
c'est pas évident de bouger on voit le
quali qui arrive pas sur les castables
il adorerait bon on dit en dessin par
exemple ce serait vraiment une case
magnifique pour lui mais c'est très loin
pour un cavalier
en deux cases en diagonale le plus long
possible 4 coups
on va aller en G5 puis on F4 puis
il faut de très grandes jambes
mais ce serait dommage de rater pour
Isler un coup facile à ce moment du
match
il va falloir rester concentré
et ne pas se désunir
quand tu quand tu es longtemps sous
pression c'est pas facile
et de continuer à jouer précis
après tu peux te reposer sur une bonne
ouverture
c'est toujours ouais
mais surtout bien se concentrer
beaucoup ici c'est pas évident
pas évidente
peut-être ou jouer fouder deux pour
chasser cette tour de la troisième
rangée éventuellement et prendre B3 et
l'attaquer celui-là
OK dans la bouger la tour sur la
troisième bon ben elle est un peu à sa
place pour remplir ses tâches défensives
le fout G2 à part la case H1 il a rien
de dispo
donc c'est pas simple d'avoir des idées
effectivement
pour améliorer cette position
il faudrait jouer quand même pour
essayer de mettre la pression autant au
moins c'est ça
je vais vite je vais vite F6 un coup
voilà bon un peu d'air au roi et qui
contrôle la case de 5 surtout donc ni la
tourne une cabine
et donc G4 jouer maintenant prends les
cases
ce que tu penses que ça peut entamer
leur force là aussi longtemps avant le
match contre ça va aller au contraire
les échauffer je me pose je sais pas
quel est ton avis là-dessus d'ailleurs
je pense à échauffe plutôt
et donc même le jour de repos peut-être
en minus ça les choses pas assez pour
demain
après c'était bo4 je t'aurais pas dit la
même chose
tu es un peu long là
ressources
c'est comme ces deux bo2 B2 ça va vite
quand même facile de Game quoi voilà ils
ont l'habitude de jouer des matchs en
quatre parties de toute façon donc
alors tour à 5 jouets tour à 5 jouets un
coup le tour transversal qui peut
peut-être préparer un coup comme H5 à un
moment d'ailleurs
toi qui est venu en B1 avec l'autre tour
qui a renforce sur ça qu'il a empêché
quoi
il a pris du pion
aussi pour attaquer le fou qui serait
sûrement reculé mais comme ça il garde
ta structure en place
et donc maintenant peut-être H5
peut-être
je sens que je voulais donc c'est dans
la suite logique des choses il a fait
thoracique et il le justifie par la
suite de son jeu
j'ai l'impression qu'il y arrivera même
pas après c'est là il y a pas assez de
pièces la paire de fouet trop forte la
position est trop ouverte
la montagne aura couché d'une souris
finalement la première partie était
sympa mais un match un peu trop facile
pour rester je dirais
on reste un peu sur notre fin oh c'est
un peu le problème avec les matchs en
deux parties c'est que ça peut aller
vite et c'est difficile de gagner à la
demande
mais toi tu fermes tout ce qui peut pour
gagner mais c'est pas facile façon
mettre le fond en C5 et
ça va être nul sans forcer sans
sourciller exactement cette pression sur
F2 qui force les pièces blanches à
rester passive
il a vraiment vraiment fait le break
dans ce match maintenant ouais c'est
impossible pour iturer de revenir ça
donne confiance quand c'est comme ça
un coup quoi
et dans la zone de finir
un petit peu ses esprits et qui fait la
tour qui se met au milieu
pour aller taperger
ouais c'est bien joué
c'est pas mal organisations
il a même plus de pions noir il peut le
prendre il peut rester en place bien sûr
ça va tourner
la case
[Musique]
j'ai quatre pour faire nul c'est fort
avec tous ces cinq peut-être à suivre
d'ailleurs
maintenant qu'il y aura plus de 8
problématique et puis peut-être échanger
ce cavalier pour bien faire des fous de
couleur opposés et bloquer ensuite sur
15 novembre
avec des coups comme B6 ou quoi mais
attendez 5 c'est pas mal c'est des
localise tous ces 5 probablement
encore bien joué
je veux cavalier 4
les joueurs qui jouent dans une belle
série de quoi et peut-être faire fou
aussi ça
va répéter il y a pas de
doute un sujet il faut 4 temps
donner le pion noir pour installer
ensuite le français 5 et ne plus bouger
donc ils sont j'ai mais il peut aussi
garder sa paire de fou qui était très
utile jusqu'à l'art
un petit coup de roi pour défendre
l'option F6 et après ne plus bouger avec
les blancs vont être ligotés
il bouge pas ils vont pas je B4 et à
pousser leur majorité à l'aile dame
sa manière de défendre et quand même
toujours assez particulier
ah ouais
systématiquement des setups que j'aurais
jamais fait quoi non mais bon ça va en
fait
j'ai revu la position qu'il avait je me
serais pas embêté à jouer le truc avec
le pion de moi quoi
mais moi attendez de torbet d'eux mais
bon c'est bizarre qu'il est laissé faire
si facilement F3 bon c'est pas grave
mais
bizarre
attendez
si ça va faire
c'est quoi
par contre
ce qui va pouvoir arriver en F4
il ferme hein
et il doit se résoudre à l'annulaire
donc Wesley ouais c'est saut qualifié et
on va faire une petite respiration et on
se retrouve très rapidement
fabiennes du loser bracket
à très vite les amis merci encore
[Musique]
c'est parti les amis
ce match Tintin tendu entre nos diabète
qui entame par E4 Wesley qui répond par
un symétrie que 5 son coup habituel pour
faire face à cette ouverture
je sais pas comment appeler le match
parce que c'est demi-finale une finale
demi-finale je pense par contre il y a
une nouveauté Fab
j'ai pas foutais
trois questions
et des idées des femmes
je crois que c'est juste de la merde
mais en fait il a préparé des Arthur un
peu poubelle pour ce pour ce tournoi et
il a battu les Van avec l'une d'elles et
qui sait ici peut-être va surprendre
cela alors ça sera pas des ouvertures
qu'on le verra trop jouer à cadence
vraiment lente mais là pourquoi pas bon
défaut de secours c'est que
tu laisses une affaire C6 te gagner un
temps sur le foot et préparer des cinq
par la suite mais il a dû un petit peu
les travailler donc il doit savoir
comment ne pas être vraiment trop mal et
avoir peut-être des pièges ici ou là
donc je m'adresse qui joue assez vite
les prochains coups
j'ai pas du tout le coup je connais pas
tellement en fait c'est un coup
qui est impressionne personne
mais bon au moins ça clou le pion des
donc pour l'instant c'est le problème à
résoudre n'importe quoi avec les Noirs
cavaliers F6 et 5 bah oui tu peux
toujours
j'ai jamais vu encore
jamais vu
par des joueurs professionnels on va
dire
très longtemps et je sais que ça a le
nom d'ouverture portugaise voilà mais
connaissance s'arrête là dessus
on sait pourquoi
je sais pas pourquoi mais je peux je
peux faire un petit coup sur
internet pour voir
alors
[Musique]
écoute c'est rien d'après Wikipédia que
tu dises rien en fait
en tout cas ça
ne mérite de faire afficher un petit peu
Wesley qui vient de jouer ses 6 donc un
coup logique pour gagner attention le
fou qui vend un A4
probablement qu'elle a l'air logique
quand même pour se développer attaquer
ce temps
même des 5 sur la tout à fait
on va voir ce qui va en tête il hésite
une avance confortable on va dire à la
pendule
un qui va commencer la partie avec quasi
3 minutes d'avance sur Wesley il doit se
délecter de ce début de très heureux
et je vous dis 5 le coup de keV
ouais c'est une scandinave améliorer
quand même bien améliorer même
ça a l'air d'être la fin de la prépa de
nous dire bac
étonnant quand même d'être
pas si bien préparé pour une ouverture
pareil il a quand même toute la journée
dans un tournoi appareil
en finale et vu toute la journée pour
réviser ses variantes il a dû penser
toute la journée
à ce coup bassin
ce serait un petit peu comme servir à la
cuillère au tennis mais normalement tu
as déjà construit ton plan mentalement
partie étonnante exactement
peut-être une partie qu'on pourra vous
remontrer en vidéo
pour cette ouverture fantastique
en tout cas ça réfléchit étonnant
j'aurais pensé justement qu'elle est
bien connaître et jouer assez vite pour
amener son adversaire sur Internet
piégeur et en fait ça va l'air juste
l'air d'être pour éviter le débat
théorique au final
non pas vraiment c'était eux quatre cinq
mais il y a un esprit 45 avec ce pion C6
et puis on des 5 mais
c'est difficile de trouver qu'un fond un
cadre dans la carotène puisqu'il faudra
passer par la case B5 contre les par le
pion c'est si alors il a pris un des
cinq dames prends et donc on a une belle
scandinave comme tu le signalais
pour ne pas y faire grand chose alors
quand même quand même cool sur ceci
c'est menacé d’âme prendre
l'ouverture c'est pas empêcher de dire
mais c'est ridicule en fait non mais
bon
[Musique]
en fait en vrai
ils prennent pas le truc au sérieux en
fait là c'est absolument rien à
en fait c'est terrible non mais là c'est
j'arrive en train de chier sur le
tournoi en fait
je sais pas si fou B5 c'est plus fort
moins fort au final
c'est quand même plus fort
encore une idée digne d'un match
championnat du monde qui est joué
pendant ce M chasse rapide ou gamevel
chasse non mais là c'est assez
[Musique]
ouvertement la gueule du truc
ça ne m'intéresse pas
à côté de ce trophée un petit coup de
trophée
il pourrait être propriétaire de ce
quand même dommage de
passer à côté
pour les blancs finalement il va se
délecter de ce début
non c'est fou quand même
étonnant
4 à 6 4 à 6 D46
on va deux fou B5 on avait des bancs les
autres années c'est quand même voilà
révolutionne les échecs quand même
vraiment du beau jeu et on se délecte
bien évidemment exactement
dommage d'ailleurs qu'il y a que deux
parties bien voulu voir ça sur quatre
huit parties
je sais pas c'est dur de se mettre
dedans là quand c'est autant
attaquer le fou à 4 au passage si jamais
contexte femme en tout cas des très très
belle partie à une nouvelle fois un
tournoi qui
ne ment pas sur ses promesses
vous avez prédit à un magnifique tournoi
et on l'a
qui se délecte du papier que je lui ai
donné ah j'ai une petite plastique du
poisson séché un peu du goût qui doit
rester
très mécontent de faire sa petite balade
alors que la plus manger du papier
dommage
qu'un magnifique partie une nouvelle
fois qu'elle échange une ouverture
rondement menée Fabien
de part et d'autre
mais surtout de la part de
du coup quatre
ça va être trop pour moi Fabien là cette
partie là c'est trop vas-y
une idée une micro prépa ou quoi parce
qu'il a quand même pas en fait c'est
vraiment c'est débile
l'important quand même qui est ce loser
bracket on le voit ceux qui ont vraiment
à cœur de rester dans le tournoi et de
revenir
pas content de ça bah imagine un match
de tennis un mec qui servait à la
cuillère et l'autre qui répondait par
des cloches en fait
et encore ça va accueillir ça peut être
bien si tu prends par surprise
cette balle qui arrive bien hauteur de
hanche tabasser mais qui te remet bien
comme il faut l'impression qu'il y a
déjà que c'est bien lorsque l'on joue
écoute théorique ou les thématiques
tactiques ouais mais c'est vrai que
Fabien et moi on n'est pas vrai ce que
tu veux être trop faible Fabien pour
pour ne pas avoir le comprendre du de
fou B5 en fait
je pense qu'il faut jouer
non mais on va dire que c'est bien de
jouer d'avoir des idées tu peux pas
juste réciter des trucs que tout le
monde connaît sinon l'un l'autre vont à
citer par cœur et il se passera rien
mais là c'est pénible
ça peut être un mix clic
ouais c'est vrai que j'écarte pas non
plus en vrai
c'est différent
mais si c'est fou les cinq pour B5 c'est
genre comment dire c'est juste mal joué
par plaisir
ouais
non plus pas terrible mais ça il joue
pas bien depuis le début du tournoi de
toute façon
mais bon il est encore là bon
les premiers matchs notamment contre
tous à Europe d'ailleurs il était
complètement gagnant on te rappelle
n'importe quoi la quatrième partie
après c'est pas passé loin plusieurs
fois mais bon on te Fabi ça a bien
tourné contre
quand
ça allait très bien bien qualité machin
il est passé à la correctionnel
donc un petit peu de réussite et même là
il a joué 4 sans avoir calculer les
conséquences de toi enfin c'est voilà
cette partie elle est quatre
alors ce que ça va donner mais c'est
étonnant quand même
en tout cas son chat est toujours aussi
beau en photo
est vraiment très très bizarre la plus
bizarre de toute celle qu'on a vu
il joue pas non c'est très long il y a
rien à voir pour l'instant donc il se
délectent d'observation
toute façon c'est un coup qui va et
sinon voilà mais ceux qui voulait
peut-être donner un pion
et
5 voilà
on va devoir se balader le long de la
quatrième rangée peut-être qu'il va
arriver à l'attaquer un peu plus
c'est bien F4 petit tu veux faire j'ai 5
c'est le vend des 4 fois 6
mais on pourra analyser avec camsest
cette partie ah oui oui il y a peut-être
dire de revoir un peu les ouvertures
ou pas
j'en sais rien
dans la bibliothèque d'ouverture il va
peut-être pas te dire que c'est mauvais
en fait
mais tu sais que je pense que les noirs
sont déjà mieux après un coup et demi
quoi
moi c'est ce que je crois
personnellement même si mon début
n'importe quoi je garderai mon avis
perso mais je pense que même l'ordi va
être d'accord
et donc la pas fait de reprendre 4 il a
du coup déplacé le Callian des quatre
et maintenant bon ce temps qui est ici 5
ou cavaliers
chose faite avec ses 5
maxime a oublié peut-être autre chose je
viens de penser peut-être qu'il est trop
saturé en CO2
mais malheureusement comme on n'a pas le
boîtier chez ses joueurs ou alors qu'ils
l'ont pas activé je sais pas peut-être
qu'il s'en servent quand même ce serait
quand même le moins de choses à un tel
niveau de compétition
en tout cas on a pas les infos et on
peut pas vous dire mais ça serait une
hypothèse effectivement saturée en CO2
il appelait la lucidité de voir d'abord
quel F3 qui est ici et il a cru
peut-être jouer en espagnol
assiste ne l'a pas surpris il a l'air A4
là le coup des 5 et surprise du coup
qu'on ne voit pas normalement espagnol
et là
[Musique]
trêve de plaisanterie mais par exemple
si tu joues une pièce en fumée à la
cigarette tu joues vraiment moins bien
quand là dans le studio moi l'été quand
j'avais pas la clim que je vois à 32 33
degrés
j'aurais eu le
Racing rouge donc oui c'est quand même
important d'avoir un boîtier comme ça
pour savoir s'il fait trop chaud dans ta
pièce si tu es en fumée et en plus tu
peux en plus faire
et l'humidité là tu la sens tu pourrais
me dire là combien de pourcentage
militaires
ce que mon téléphone il peut me dire la
température ou pas je sais pas je pense
pas il y a pas de carte de température
c'est humide bah tu m'étonnes j'arrive
pas à bien jouer l'été voilà
alors comment baisser le taux d'humidité
chez soi maintenant je vais regarder
comment baisser
le taux
d'humidité je vais regarder
je pense que je dois racheter tout un
tas de trucs là maintenant
j'ai un déshumidificateur je pense que
c'est
l'humidité dans un récipient déposer
quelques cuillères et un salut dans la
pièce humide de votre logement
déjà tu fous du sel un peu partout salle
de partout en fait
après ce qu'il y a d'autres conseils à
part de mettre du sel un peu partout
dans la pièce
des humidificateurs voilà bon ça j'y
avais pensé et ben il y a
encore de troisième solution
je sais pas s'ajouter peut-être
le soupe d'allumer un feu ça pourrait
bien marcher
si mineur c'est foutu
voilà c'est ultra humide dehors c'est
pour ça en fait que la chaleur elle
prend autant en fait il y a beaucoup
d'humidité dans l'air le je la
aussi chaud ici et je comprends pas
pourquoi les gens viennent en vacances
ici il était
c'est tellement con
c'est parce qu'il y a de plus agréable
non
assez quand ils abrutis à un endroit
où nous on rêver de partir en fait
je sais pas
je regarde
ça serait bien ça serait le complément
idéal
en tout cas les choses ont un petit peu
évolué les gens moins de 5 minutes
maintenant
pas j'avais beaucoup de trous seulement
12 c'est 5 la double attaque
elle est vraiment bizarre
OK
F5 on est d'accord ce que j'avais de
base
qu'elle pleutre ça gagne une pièce c'est
ça que c'était Baqué par l'ordi il doit
y avoir un truc pas si simple
je sais pas quoi c'est une pièce
ouais
c'est normal c'est une pièce c'est une
pièce
la partie c'est peut-être la pire qu'on
va du tournoi là
parce que c'est ouais hier c'était
tellement bien
je sais pas si c'est aussi bien qu'hier
ou pas hier on s'est quand même au
dessus peut-être
[Musique]
partie ça peut pas te mettre au même
plan que les matériaux
grand jeu
avec la qualification en ligne de mire
pour la finale pour retrouver Magnus
Carson
dans un match en quatre parties de
nouveau mais si ça perd dedans deux
parties après exactement je vous
expliquera ça tout ça demain
2 minutes pour pour
la première partie du tournage je trouve
qu'il y a un peu en dessous en termes de
contenu le reste c'était vraiment
extraordinaire là c'est la première ça
joue un peu moins bien alors de justesse
malgré tout
faire une tactique difficile avec ses 5
ratés
[Musique]
de ce clouage et donc grand rock vient
peut-être plus spontanément à l'esprit
où on se laisse sûrement entamer par
l'effort quand même qui a suscité la
partie précédente contre hit wit saga il
a dû réaliser au coup de bambou ton
anniversaire dans la deuxième partie où
il y a du défendre avec un pion de moi
quand même pour très longtemps il y
arrive après un effort titanas comme tu
viens le signaler
et donc là peut-être il paye l'effort
juste avant il a du mal à suivre le
rythme de son adversaire d'ailleurs il a
moins de 2 minutes alors que cette offre
a plus de 3 minutes pour moi c'est pas
normal qu'il soit éliminé complètement
nutorrent après ce match où il peut pas
vraiment défendre ses chances à 100%
Maxime Bachard tu as atteint vraiment de
voir après
tant attendu
il sait pas extraordinaire aujourd'hui
c'est simplement merveilleux merci
Marlow merci
j'imagine chez lui avec des masques des
joues différentes
après une telle intensité toi d'être
demain j'étais invité à un mariage mais
évidemment annuler vous avez bien raison
tous
[Musique]
il y aura pas deux fois une finale comme
demain
trophée qui sera remis à la suite de la
partie au vainqueur je vais repasser
Fabien
j'ai peur de mes mots quoi
donc on en est là
F6 c'est pas passé grand chose tant
qu'on a admirer le trophée
4 nous on joue à tout ça
comme ça sur ces 5 il voit kb5
intercepté l'attaque du Fou des scènes
sur le cavalier
[Musique]
c'est trop non mais moi aussi je
reprenne
mieux comment
ouais c'est peut-être tu en as peut-être
un air qui fait rire tu as du gaz des
fois
ventilation de la pièce
c'est la bonne humeur en tout cas
mais comment ne pas être refa bien
devant ce spectacle il y a pas
franchement F6 c'est tout recette
en tout cas plus trop de temps
la partie est tellement bizarre il y a
rien qui va quoi il y a rien de logique
tout le monde peut gagner
on serait beau qui perdent sur déco
peut tomber tu peux arriver alors il a
pris le pion en D2 et l'autre il prend
B4 pour l'instant il était matériel puis
peut-être des échanges massifs qui est
mieux
personne peut-être
bien joué il veut échanger et faire
cavalier F6 finale le développement
finalement
je pense qu'une telle partie se mérite
de se terminer par la nul quand même
de genre qu'on était au coude à coup
tout au long de la partie ils doivent
être tous les deux avec le temps avec
les Noirs
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'il te répète
il répète
peut être plus actif dans la finale un
petit peu quoi
pour ces 7
tu es bien là
chasse le cavalier pour peut-être avoir
rangé trois qui arrivent trois
ok les cas ça a l'air hyper fort
je sais pas pourquoi il le fait pas
OK
tellement pas comment il sait
après c'est très bien joué il blinde
mais genre j'ai jamais les mêmes idées
que lui quoi ne t'a jamais des coups H4
et ça change beaucoup de choses parce
que du coup
recette et merci au revoir il s'est fait
avoir par le par la mare loutre mauvais
prix au mauvais moment
anticipé par Wesley
5 je sais pas si ton tour à 4 ouais 4
c'est fort
fermez peut-être
à 5
ouais 6
et tous les côtés
et ça déroule
on va faire une petite respiration une
petite pause on se retrouve bientôt pour
peut-être je n'espère évidemment pas la
dernière partie de la journée à tout de
suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyser avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs ils
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour se
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
alors c'est reparti Wesley qui entamé
par le coup 4 et son adversaire par le 5
F3 de Wesley alors à noter que dans la
même situation 3 jours plutôt lundi
dernier Wesley qu'on sépare D4 premier
coup on avait vu un grand bidame avec la
structure Carlsbad
et Wesley avait pris un bel avantage
avant de ne pas oser attaquer et perdre
et là donc il joue au 4 il joue que 16
de Kev on attend avec impatience on
arrive pour l'expertise dans l'ouverture
en tout cas Wesley qui a bien joué Caval
F3 avant fou B5
mieux jouer mieux jouer au second coup
et donc écossaise écossaise de Wesley
qui n'a besoin que du nul et qui joue
pendant l'écossaise ouverture agressive
mais en même temps on sait que les noirs
[Musique]
normalement peut-être le meilleur coup
c'est cavalier 6 qui peut conduire à des
ventes assez égales et donc si tu joues
fou B4 un petit peu comme dans la partie
précédente provoque le coup C3 et recule
maintenant c'est 5 donc ce qui va éviter
certaines variantes mais donner d'autres
choix au blanc
[Musique]
que voici que voilà exactement
je vais me délecter de cette partie
Fabien
sûrement on fait non ici
et on reprend et peut-être après ces
quatre et on joue pour ce genre de cases
une passion assez solide
c'est pas possible c'est juste la F5
bien sûr érudit qu'il connaît tout
donc ce cavalier attaque G7 et surtout
l'idée c'est en cas d'échange le cas il
se rapatrie et aura une case de choix
pour venir ensuite en D5 peut-être
épauler par son collègue on a pas mal
joué dernièrement je respecte absolument
pas bon c'est pas c'est pas une
réputation très pour garder la confiance
j'ai pas de chèque alors dis pour voir
si c'était devenu bien ça je prends pour
des cons j'aime bien faire ça des fois
ils se mettent à jouer un truc au début
tant que ça me pose pas de problème je
regarde même pas
parce qu'après des fois tu vois que
l'ordi dit que ça va
tu commences à te faire découvrir
5 à un moment pour rétablir un peu les
choses mais ça marche pas
dans un manche j'ai appris par coeur
parce que c'était revenu un peu à la
mode là c'est revenu mais bon
j'ai pu par cœur mais
j'aime beaucoup ce chat
il est très bien très beau
malheureusement la dernière partie du
jour les amis ça peut
sauf si vous êtes imposer ce qu'on
espère évidemment oui
finalement de loser bracket ou demi
finale je suis en comme on le voit
aurait quand même pu se jouer en quatre
parties à mon avis voilà pour bien se
réchauffer pour demain
et aussi quand c'est un match à gros
enjeu et donc
voilà il y a de l'enjeu F3 et C4 et
cavalier C3
une ligne avec qui
trois jouets par Wesley
D6 et donc probablement le coup c'est 4
replacer le caille bien en C3 soit une
belle case
voilà
il était complètement gagnant il avait
craqué
et c'est toute la force de ce format ça
va lui permettre peut-être de se
qualifier quand même
pour la finale
la fronde sont bourreau du premier jour
on prend peut-être une revanche juteuse
on incarne il n'a pas vécu ça
non
oui oui
encore une partie assez magnifique pour
le moment que de spectacle déjà sur ses
premiers coups
après il faut un plan où ils essayent
d'échanger le fou contre un cavalier te
jouer sur case noir
bon logique vu la structure
mais c'est pas bon
quelque chose qu'on fait jamais en jean
est-ce que Dame des deux grands rock ce
serait si idiot pour faire G4 et avancer
de l'autre côté
dernièrement ils ont commencé à jouer un
peu ce plan aussi
c'est une question
novice pas vraiment cette position alors
moi je fais généralement avec Europe
me questionne des anciens est-ce que
grand rock serait si mal ici parce que
pas évident de voir qu'on est noir
attaquent sur ce
steldame puisque ils ont pas tellement
d'espace pas tellement de pièces qui
passent pas tellement de perception pour
venir nous ouvrir la position
c'était juste une question comme ça
en passant
en tout cas elle a choisi des trois
qui développe le fou prépare le petit
rock
elle est en cata pour nous dire bec
là c'est à côté de son match
peut-être encore remis de d'hier
troisième partie
qui est dominé il avait la position
gagnante
et n'est pas su concluant une position
de pas si dur à terminer
tellement de contrôle sur la position
pour
l'autre il aurait pu être peut-être
tenter de faire Dame des deux d'un
match4 d'un F2 changer les dames qui
étaient probablement possible j'ai
l'impression que ça le favorise un peu
quand même la présence des dames sur
cette échiquier vu son avantage d'espace
peut-être qu'il a retenu le son du
premier jour et qui va jouer en
adéquation avec la position
il a requé il a une belle avance à la
pendule et il y a pas vraiment de plan
pour les noirs qui doivent plutôt
attendre et essayer de s'engouffrer
si une porte s'ouvre
un fouet
et
17 on est en C5 ou en E5 mais c'est vrai
que tout F2 ça a l'air pas mal ou tout
droit d'ailleurs ou tourcé 1 comme ça
sur KSI 5 ou quoi il y aura toujours du
fou qui se retirait en B1 après ça c'est
peut-être une histoire de goût
Le Gall
magnifique partie en tout cas pour le
moment
qui joue déjà F4 il prend même pas le
temps de spécialement préparé parce que
sa position est assez mûre pour ce genre
de coup et il va
elle a tellement une belle position je
sais pas comment ça peut lui échapper
après il avait gaffé
cases noires mais en tout cas pas trop
d'espace les blancs peut-être des
perspectives allaient le droit s'il le
souhaite par la suite
stabiliserait ce qui est valide en
bécane
gênant pour la Torin
donc
jouer à trois pour enlever ce cavalier
pour retirer le fou et ensuite il a
participé la tour au jeu ce serait
logique
parti et particulière
au centre mais du coup un peu étonnant
ce coup de fou c'est de alors appeler
directement B1 si je le souhaite est
tellement
à 3 jours
donc à B3 allez logique conserver une
belle structure une belle chaîne de
pions
ça m'est arrivé de perdre des parties
avec ce scénario là justement depuis
quoi comme ça
[Musique]
le temps de jeter un œil la finale
féminine champion mais malheureusement
non avec cet emploi du temps
très chargé
cette finale Fabien malheureusement
après bon je me tiens au courant du
score je crois que là il mène mais bon
on ne peut pas avoir plus que le score
après je sais que le match va déménager
en cours de route peut-être d'ailleurs
là ou prochainement
chacune des joueuses jouant dans sa
ville de résidence ou d'origine la
moitié du match
elle fait un beau match de jouer n'était
à priori favorite avant le début de la
rencontre mais là après si ronde une
victoire 5 nulles donc pour cette
challengeuse
je sais pas
qui au niveau
un bon match
le match parfait
tout ce qu'il fallait pas faire en fait
se retrouver très mauvais fou la tour
qui joue pas
comme ça et depuis je laisse plus faire
à trois
voilà
ça tu laisses l'autre là-bas
réclament la même case au final une fois
qu'on a dans les deux si lui venait ici
on aura quand même à l'oeil celui-là on
serait peut-être pas si simple à mettre
en place surtout que les Blancs
aimeraient attaquer peut-être aller le
droit quand même dans une situation
c'est intéressant effectivement
et peut-être des damage 6 qui aurait pu
arriver sur 5 cela dit mais à calculer
quand même
un petit peu
H4 on peut pas laisser les pièces
coulisser vers la Gaza 3
tours
il a été perdant très rapidement la
partie du rap à peine 5 minutes je pense
pas vraiment eu le temps de délecter de
délecter justement de la partie à peine
arrivé déjà fini
un petit peu dommage quelque part
il y avait pas plus délecter
mais nous non plus d'ailleurs par la
même occasion
c'est difficile
un petit peu de tennis
dommage
pas faux
d'électrons
des deux joueurs dans le tournoi
peut-être le moment de faire F5 ici
les non pas accès à la case de 5 avec le
cheval joli coup F5
parce que on a fait les cases mais pas
de bonne pièce à y mettre dessus c'est
juste visuel et rail connu quand même
partie
qui fait un coucou F5
quand même
un petit peu moins puissant maintenant
qu'on a pas enfermé le foie de verse
quand même bien
S
tu peux quand même
[Musique]
point F5 pour toi F4
en tout cas partie intense qui tient
toutes ses promesses
de ce tournoi on laisse avec les Blancs
va-t-il résister à la Furious bec
rien n'est moins sûr
joue le F5 maintenant
dis pas contre sens mais ça passe quand
même
l'échange des dames l'échange des fous
change de beaucoup de pièces on rappelle
que Wesley peut se
contenter d'une petite partie nul
d'ailleurs se targuer de jouer pour
annuler aussi
je vais faire beaucoup de choses
Fabien quel spectacle
les dames sont échangent les fous
échanges ou est-ce qu'il ramène son roi
un petit peu en jeu
les Noirs mais qui pourrait donner une
faiblesse
tu fais bien de le signaler
ouais
vers le centre
on est un taxe pion on décide défendu
instantanément
très bien joué vraiment très propre de
la part du joueur américain le roi qui
peut monter soutenir les pions et
s'activer au même
occasion
j'ai 6 mais une petite pression sur la
chaîne de pions des blancs
c'est bien joué hein c'est très bien
c'est très propre pour l'instant garde
une belle avance à la pendule il gère
bien
H5 évite peut-être une consolidation par
G4
et attendre
[Musique]
plus défendre la tour là haut et les
noirs du matériel dès lors il ne peut
pas jouer de la sorte et le 5 donc un
coup qui va attaquer ce pion une fois de
plus on a trois attaquants avec les
Blancs seulement deux défenseurs côté
noir donc il va falloir choisir quoi
jouer
pour arriver sur ici c'est sûrement pas
passionnant côté noir donc peut-être
de faire des beaux échanges je pense
c'est terminé
match exceptionnel encore une fois
Fabien dans
de voir qu'ils nous ont gratifié d'un
niveau de jeu impressionnant pour aller
travailler sur une chaise
il a dû le faire d'ailleurs lundi pour
apprendre de ses erreurs et aujourd'hui
revenir plus fort et ne pas les réitérer
on prend des 6 en tout cas il met échec
au roi
qui part en F6
donc voilà il y a un très beau pion
passé pour les blancs
qui va limiter le jeu adverse
du bonheur
arrive à une case du bonheur tout à fait
soutenu peut-être par un cavalier après
qu'elle est bien le coup de cœur
[Musique]
très bien joué tout en maîtrise après en
plus tu peux avoir des C5 et C4
et ça s'annonce grouper
tu as un moule
tour à 8 pour défendre le pion peut-être
maintenant forcer la tour allez en D8
donc c'est une belle colonne ouverte qui
va se retrouver tristement sur cette
case D8 ou ne contrôle plus grand chose
elle est obstruée par ce pion qui les
prend les cases
adjacentes à la tour
n'ayons pas peur des mots
il va y avoir 4 on peut monter mais là
bien joué le califourra revenir si
jamais pour l'instant il fait le travail
il limite cette tour à 8 là-bas
donc c'est tout en souplesse la peur de
Wesley dans son élément 4 minutes
d'avance à la pendule tout pile
le toupie
abandonner côté
on a grandi espoir en tout cas qu'il a
défendent vivre un nouvel Armageddon ce
serait vraiment le clou du spectacle
pour ce soir
on ne pourrait rêver meilleur scénario
mais je suis quand même un peu un petit
peu inquiet
cavalier qui repartit qui veut peut-être
venir mettre un petit peu de pression
sur spion 17 il était beau en B4 mais
maintenant c'était trop bien défendu à
deux donc c'est résolu à faire demi-tour
recette ramène l'or un peu la défense ce
pion qui est le danger numéro 1 dans la
position des Noirs donc il faut quand
même surveiller tel le lait sur le feu
bon les blancs
ou alors sortir le cavalier pourquoi pas
il a pris F5
il joue simplement et de manière logique
peut-être tenter un petit piège
alors il y a pas de B4 là qui est prend
des 7
c'est 5
puisque
j'aurai toutes les tours une belle
finale de cavalier avec un pion de plus
un roi actif qui pourrait aller chercher
aussi ce pion très bien jouer B4 ça a
l'air d'un être fini
fini tôt Pipo mais peut-être tant que B3
quand même si jamais le pion venait à
partir pour épousset après qu'il y avait
trois C5
belle manière d'abandonner que j'aurais
pu être un joli coup je me souviens sur
ICC quand tu avais qu'un coup tu fais
juste cliquer et le pion par terre là
non
mais du coup un mystique aura été
possible là quand même B3 ça quand même
dommage de ne pas se qualifier pour la
finale sur une telle erreur
il reste plus qu'une minute à tout ça tu
auras
peut-être revenir en 6
c'est ce qui fait
je crois que son tour
il fait baisser 5 il veut rien lâcher
pas donner de pion
pas forcément le meilleur coup mais ça
ça devrait faire le taf
je vais t'attaquer le bout je t'attaque
le cahier sur la route
et maintenant peut-être l'autre qui va
aller va venir par ici
façon tout gagne
25 secondes pour avoir plus que même si
rate le gars nul suffit
d'en jeu
ça fait un cavalier C3 ici
étonnante fin de partie Fabien
c'est la pression son adversaire un coup
si naturel
c'est chose faite
17 secondes pour abdos
5 rois froid des 8 kf6 3 8 KFC 7 3 F8
seul coup car il est C7 pour D8 ouais
bon rien ne bouge plus
c'est terminé merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi la journée avec nous et on se
retrouve
demain pour la suite et fin cette finale
tant attendue entre Wesley Sow et Magnus
Carlson à demain ciao ciao à demain bye
bye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]